تعالوا كيف حالكم الحمد لله من وين انتم
من بيت حنون بيت حنون بيت حنون ايش هذا
اللي مش سقعان انت والله والله برد وين
وين في خيمت ايش انتم في مدرسه رابعه
مدرسه رابعه رابعه ايش بتساوي مع بعض عد
عدين لا تفرجيني ايدك
حبيبي سقع ايدك سقع شاطرين ايش نفسكم كل
في كل شي كل شيكل شي كل شي كل شي والله
اعطيكم شحق
طب انت نفسك نفسك في الاندومي صح طب هي
وانت ايش نفسك في الاندومي خلاص هيك نفسكم
تمام لا احنا مش ما خلصنا وانت نفسك في هذ
وانت في
هذ كمان كمان كمان وانت ها وانت ها كمان
لا يسلمك خلاص طماعين احنا مش طماعين لكن
انا بقول لكم ابشروا خيرا هذه تشتروا فيها
نفسك فيه ابدا يا را لا الاولادي مش ابدا
انتم اولى من الاولادي على فكره اقول لك
ليش ل لانه انتم اولادي وحياه الله كل طفل
بغزه ابني يسعد لي قلبكم يلا سلام بدكم شي
لا حبيبي الله ي حبيبي يسعد قلبهم
وهذا
ه